et comme chaque mercredi maintenant nous
partons à la découverte d'une école ou
d'une formation sur le territoire des
Yvelines et c'est avec vous Régina
ralech ce soir vous allez nous parler de
bucource oui c'est ça Mathilde on va
parler de ducre source et elle est
spécialisée dans les métiers du
médico-social et ce soir on va parler
plus précisément du diplôme pour devenir
éducateur spécialisé et alors justement
est-ce que vous avez une définition de
ce métier éducateur spécialisé tout à
fait c'est une personne qui accompagne
au quotidien des enfants des adolescents
ou des adultes qui présentent un
handicap mental ou physique des
difficultés sociales ou d'insertion et
l'éducateur spécialisé permet à ces
personnes de devenir autonome de
retrouver confiance en elle ou bien
d'apaiser un climat en tension au sein
d'une famille par exemple alors comment
est-ce qu'on fait régime pour devenir
éducateur spécialisé alors il faut
obtenir un test donc c'est le diplôme
d'état d'éducateur spécialisé c'est une
licence donc ça se fait en trois ans et
à but ressources en 2022 92% des
étudiants ont obtenu leur diplôme leur
cursus les étudiants alternent entre
stages et enseignement théorique il faut
compter 60 semaines de stage sur les
trois années confondues et pour l'école
il y a une réelle intention de
professionnaliser les apprenants et de
les confronter aux réalités du terrain
et comme vous l'avez dit Mathilde
justement n'avait avec nous Charlène
Garcia bonsoir bonsoir donc que vous
êtes éducatrice spécialisé ce que vous
pouvez nous parler un peu plus en
amplement de votre expérience au sein de
l'école et quels sont les matières que
vous avez étudiées alors du coup à but
ressources on va travailler évidemment
tout ce qui est sociologie la
psychologie on va travailler les
différents handicaps ou aussi situation
de vie que peuvent avoir certaines
personnes comme les SDF ou les personnes
souffrant d'addiction aussi et tout ce
qui est dans le champ de la protection
de l'enfance donc les foyers pour
enfants ou directement de travailler au
niveau des crises aussi familiales donc
finalement c'est quelque chose qui est
large oui c'est un métier qui permet de
changer facilement de domaine en fait
c'est ça la richesse justement et
justement c'est tricher vous avez pu
l'exploiter au travers de stage
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire
plus dessus oui alors à ducrosour
souvent on essaye de préconiser de faire
dans les trois chambres donc le chant de
l'insertion le champ de la protection de
l'enfance et le champ de handicap
maintenant au niveau de l'insertion
c'est un champ qui est assez difficile
d'accéder en tant que stagiaire parce
que les problématiques vont être
multiples on va être souvent sur des
personnes qui sont vraiment
marginalisées dans la rue en comptant
des problèmes d'addictologie des
problèmes de situation aussi au niveau
des papiers pour rester en France etc
donc c'est un champ qui est assez dur à
intégrer en tant que stagiaire on va
dire ou alternant
moi j'ai pu faire notamment dans
l'handicap psychique en accompagnant des
personnes souffrant d'handicap comme
la schizophrénie la bipolarité ensuite
j'ai fait un stage en masse donc maison
d'accueil spécialisée qui accompagne des
personnes avec un polyhandicap donc
moteur et
psychique pardon et ensuite j'ai fait
dans un foyer pour enfants adolescent
donc une mex maison d'enfants à
caractère social on a beaucoup
d'heroglyphes
pour des jeunes de 13 à 18 ans pardon et
donc aujourd'hui vous travaillez dans
quoi après toutes ces expériences de
stage vous avez choisi quel domaine
alors là j'ai arrêté les foyers et je
suis dans un service éducatif de
proximité qui appartient comme un
bucrossos à la sauvegarde des Yvelines
donc il y a nous avons un service à
Saint-Cyr à Houilles et aux Mureaux pour
pour pouvoir regrouper et intervenir sur
toutes les Yvelines donc on a on
accompagne des adolescents
qui rencontrent une crise au sein de la
cellule familiale qui sont dans une
situation de marginalisation dont les
parents ne comprennent pas et ont besoin
d'un tiers justement pour apaiser et on
est souvent vu comme une alternative au
placement et donc quelle est la qualité
qu'il faut avoir absolument pour pour
faire ce métier là finalement
l'adaptation il faut s'adapter au public
toutes les personnes sont différentes on
a un besoin différent et des capacités
différentes et comme un éducateur
spécialisé doit faire un projet avec la
personne qui l'accompagne en fonction de
ses besoins de ses envies et de surtout
de ses capacités donc je dirais plus
l'adaptation l'écoute évidemment et la
bienveillance et qu'est-ce qui vous
plaît le plus dans ce métier qu'on peut
bouger on peut changer de personnes
accompagnées de services il y a beaucoup
de possibilités de la remise en question
les formations c'est un métier très
riche sur l'humain ou tout est basé sur
l'échange on travaille souvent en équipe
pluridisciplinaire à l'aide de
psychologue ça peut être aussi des
psychiatres des
ergothérapeutes vraiment ça peut être
très riche au niveau des métiers qui
nous accompagnent et donc j'imagine que
c'est un métier qui est pas toujours
évident au quotidien quelle distance ou
qu'elle proximité ce que vous pouvez
avoir avec les personnes que vous
accompagnez c'est la grande question de
l'éducation spécialisée durant ma
formation c'est une question qui est
très souvent abordée en cours notamment
parce que c'est vous qui choisissez la
distance je dirais pas qu'il n'y a une
formule magique qui fait que on y pense
pas à la maison et que le cerveau est
reposé directement
on essaye de nous dire de faire
attention de savoir prendre de la
distance et notamment s'il y a autant de
semaines de stage dans cette formation
c'est pour savoir si on est apte en fait
à en vivre et
de se sentir assez à l'aise aussi en
tant que vie professionnelle et vie
perso mais finalement c'est quelque
chose que vous jaugez en fonction en
fait des personnes que vous rencontrez
et en fonction des publics tous les
publics ça va pas être la même chose en
fonction de nous aussi notre personne
notre personnalité il y a des publics on
n'arrive plus à couper le cerveau quand
on rentre à la maison que d'autres
et le ministère de l'enseignement
supérieur indique qu'il y a une chute de
38% quant aux candidatures sur
parcoursup ce que vous pouvez nous dire
pourquoi et qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait
faire justement pour attirer les jeunes
vers cette filière alors
quand j'ai commencé
je suis rentrée dans cette école à 18
ans et j'ai remarqué que c'était surtout
un métier de reconversion en fin de
compte parce qu'on en parle pas du tout
de ces de ces métiers là c'est un métier
méconnu moi à l'époque je le connaissais
pas du tout j'ai dû un peu chercher même
beaucoup
je pense qu'à le salaire évidemment tout
augmente dans notre société actuelle et
c'est un salaire qui est quand même qui
commence assez bas donc à Microsoft on
peut devenir éducateur spécialisé mais
on peut être aussi moniteur éducateur et
AMP
j'ai pas les hiéroglyphes mais on est
plus sur un accompagnement éducatif et
médical avec une formation d'un an et
demi pour accompagner les personnes en
situation d'handicap moteur
principalement
c'est des métiers qui n'ont pas besoin
du bac et vu que c'est une
reconnaissance de
Bac + un bac + 2 à mon époque on va dire
que le salaire ne suivait pas non plus
donc j'ai pu discuter déjà avec des
jeunes et ils m'ont dit que c'était
notamment la première raison après je
pense qu'il y a aussi la difficulté
psychologique on va dire parce que
souvent on nous dit mais comment vous
faites pour supporter
on sait pas non plus comment on fait et
je pense que c'est pour ça que je vous
dis vraiment que c'est en fonction du
public qu'on accompagne et notre
personnalité qui fait qu'on arrive à
supporter les désarroi des personnes
qu'on peut accompagner et alors si vous
aviez un conseil à donner aux étudiants
au futur étudiants ou au lycéens qui
souhaiteraient rentrer dans cette école
pour leur donneriez quoi comme conseil
que si il pense que c'est le bon endroit
pour eux ils peuvent y arriver
maintenant après ça va être la prise de
recul moi je pense que c'est d'abord il
faut qu'on accompagne à l'humain il faut
aller bien soi-même c'est le premier
conseil qu'on donne c'est si nous on a
réglé nos soucis personnels parce que
c'est un métier qui fait beaucoup écho
aussi à nos situations on va on
travaille la relation avec les parents
on travaille les traumatismes et nous
aussi en tant que travailleur on peut
avoir à faire à ça dans notre vie
personnelle et il faut être prêt à
pouvoir
par en rediscuter de sa vie personnelle
mais de se remettre là-dedans en
accompagnant les personnes qui sont en
train de le vivre justement
et bien merci beaucoup Charline Garcia
d'être venu parler de votre métier et
éducatrice spécialisée et puis de votre
ancienne école Buc ressources